hey welcome to the Reuben report I'm
still Dave Reuben I've got bree essrig
and whitney mixter and let's roll all
right Anthony Weiner mr. penis on
Twitter he is running for mayor of New
York City he announced it last week and
amazingly he's already second in the
Democratic primary 19% compared to
Christine Quinn's 24% Chrissy Quinn is a
lesbian by the way which basically means
this whole thing is a referendum on the
penis I think anyway let's take a look
at mr. Weiner's first video and look I
made some big mistakes and I know I let
a lot of people down but I've also
learned some tough lessons I'm running
for mayor cuz I've been fighting for the
middle class and those struggling to
make it my entire life and I hope I get
a second chance to work for you New York
City should be the middle-class capital
of the world and I've got some ideas on
how to do it
sixty-four of them write on my website
take a look tell me what you think we
love this city and no one will work
harder to make it better than Anthony I
will fight for you every single day
thank you for watching okay so there was
a little terror in his wife's face there
but basically I thought it was a pretty
good video and I'm kind of on board the
Weiner train here I think we all sort of
have to forgive him and move on and
there is gonna be stuff of all of us out
there and I think it would be cathartic
for New York in the country if we just
let it go do you guys think that the
penis can get a pass on this three you
heard you know I probably should have
read this cuz I thought this whole thing
was about a dachshund named Anthony but
now I mean I love how he was sitting in
like the cleanest part of New York like
on like the cleanest stoop
yeah well you have to because he can't
be in like a crack den now he's already
associated with sex you can't have him
but does that exist in New York I clean
Stu yeah Whitney are there clean spaces
there might be one I haven't found it
yet but you know you did find it I think
the thing here is the the amount of puns
potential puns are limitless
I mean Weiner comes from behind
Quinn is still on top you know I think
the initial closer in the polls but you
know I think I think you know New
Yorkers especially love you know love a
guy that rolls up his sleeves like he
did and when he when he just recently
did the press comments whatever it was
stands up when he talks you know and and
you can google his [ __ ] yeah they like
that down-home type so I think he's got
a chance yeah I really though I really
believe that it would be good for
everyone to forgive him like people are
freaking out about you know can we
forgive him and we saw his penis but
don't you think it will actually be good
because this is gonna happen who else
will be able to run for office
ever if we can't forgive this one
because he's just the first you know the
last time that happened I mean you know
it just totally bought threw me off my
game now so continue please I think it
would be good for all of us like that's
the thing that it's not that I believe
in him so much but I think the idea of a
second chance I always I always like to
give people the benefit of that and I
love scandal so when something happens
I'm just like yes yeah you yes you will
make headlines you will make things
funnier so I think and as a performer
that's really what you so this isn't
about you don't live in New York so it's
not about being a constituent does my is
my opinion even valid no will he do more
SNL skits about it sure that's all I
care about so I mean it's and the
scandal at least he did it before he got
into office you know so it's like oh I
got that out of the way you know you
guys all right yeah so you know what
kudos to you Anthony Weiner yeah don't
you guys think though it's possible that
he'll actually have to be an honest
politician because of this like he
already is done something that is so
scandalous like it doesn't get much more
scandalous than the penis like he'd have
to be honest now which most politicians
have to be the reverse
a great point yeah so I it sounds like
we have three people backing Anthony
Weiner none of us live in New York
anymore that's true wait okay maybe I'm
confused
yeah is he gay no okay yeah you really
want now let's start another scandal oh
yes gay gay I wanted to throw that out
there I want to start the rumor that day
yeah then why was he then who's that
woman he's sitting on the stoop with an
actress just somebody should be a rep
fool ya what do you think about the wife
though cuz she she always looks like
she's just like I mean I'm already in
this deep I might as well just finish
off this right you know like it's like
oh yeah
she just has this look of I'm just tired
yeah but you know he he was fairly well
undead so maybe that's why he's right
that's why she what he's running and
he's running against a lesbian Chris
laughs why are we not voting for her why
are we not yes why why are we giving him
a second chance and not voting for her I
like Christina I do like Christine Quinn
she's really really good voting for him
right now and then but now that I think
about it I kind of don't want to and I
kind of want to you yeah does a lesbian
have to vote for another lesbian as a
general rule if I'm it's like pretty
much you gotta vote for though I think
it's just more just like women have to
vote for women it's yeah that's what I
feel like I mean especially I don't know
I just
especially okay and I just I don't want
to be a hypocrite girl just that I would
give him a second chance
but he does have all this baggage yeah
polish Wow yeah you're changed pretty
quick I just did yeah yeah now that I
think about it I don't know although
that commercial or that little promo he
made that was really wonderful yeah well
did you guys hear that in that promo the
beginning shot actually was in
Pittsburgh or something I wasn't yeah
and then the image on his website on
Anthony Weiner dot-com of course was an
image from yeah
I think he should have like gone with
like another pun to and he's like
there's all 64 of them on my website
it's like just stick with the theme and
be like there's 69 I'm out you know do
you think we're ever gonna have a
politician that we're not going to see
his genitals in the future like it seems
to me that you know what do you mean
like anyone that's of a certain age now
this stuff is just out there the webcam
is on everyone's computer that's why I
feel like we have to forgive him for
this because other and also what does
politics have to do with morals like I
feel like penis pics every politics
morals now what do they have to do with
you're so right yeah that's why it seems
to me that like when he's sitting there
on the stoop with his wife and they look
so happy it's like you know what she
doesn't have to be that happy she could
just be like I'm sticking with this guy
and his frickin wiener but all right
well I don't know that we got any votes
for wiener there we might have helped
Christine Quinn and that's just the
Democratic primary so you know they're
gonna run against the Republicans so
we'll see what happens all right let's
move on
so CNN which used to be a very reputable
news organization and now is a place for
Wolf Blitzer to futz around all day they
have joined forces with BuzzFeed which
is basically like the hottest thing
online and BuzzFeed is going to be
producing a couple videos for CNN each
week probably about three on a YouTube
channel and people are saying this is
gonna make CNN cool it's gonna give cred
to BuzzFeed
I don't know that BuzzFeed needs any
more cred because I give BuzzFeed a lot
of cred do you guys think that like old
media and new media can combine and not
destroy each other yeah I didn't think
could I think it's a good it's a better
idea for CNN to put BuzzFeed on their
radar as opposed to buzz to be putting
CNN because when I look at BuzzFeed
articles I want to see pictures with
funny captions I don't want to see news
I don't want to see videos yeah if I see
if I click it and I see oh there's a
video oh no
I don't have time for that I want to
just like read a little funny pictures I
want to see 27 pictures of cute cats and
dresses by the way did you guys hear
that last week they announced that the
dot gif fits now it's pronounced gf
oh you knew that already because didn't
the guy who invented it or something he
and he officially laid down the law
it's jiff I thought it was gift you know
is is does this tell you the state of
CNN and just news in general that they
have to combine with a site that really
is known for cat pictures honestly I
think it's more telling of the society
how much the status of news but it's
like how much attention span do we have
in this new like adderall induced youth
society of news you know I think it's
like how many images can we cram in over
sad music in a minute because I watched
the video yeah did you watch the I
watched the video and I thought going
into it I thought so they pick up one
piece right they put up one piece and it
was a montage of all the rescues of the
best rescues of 2000 whatever yeah and
so I was like going into it I'm like
this isn't gonna work for me like you
know and by the end of it I was like no
it's not something I I don't know
yeah do you think it's bad for our brain
chemistry that even now we have to get
our news in such like I love Twitter I
say it every week on this show and I
tweet like crazy but like that actually
might be doing something to our brains
that everything we do and you talked
about adderall a second ago that
everything we do is such quick short
bites and we're not giving ourselves
like any room in our brain to get those
neurons connecting to other things I
blame it on Sponge Bob Squarepants
though they did that study showing that
kids that watch that show like are more
likely to develop a TD really yeah
no no I've only seen spongebob one
choice but it's a lot of quick yeah I
watched it a lot of the cave and I was
diagnosed with ADB really legitimately
yes yeah so
I blame that you believe spongebob would
and what do you think I don't know
what's blame I not didn't watch
Spongebob but I can only imagine was all
the other horrible cartoons that yeah
yeah I don't know but you know what I
still feed into it the short bursts of
news yeah and Twitter and Instagram
things that you know your brain is
constantly working you never get a
chance to rest and really absorb
nowadays so I think that's their only
option yeah do you guys think it says
more about CNN or more about BuzzFeed
like to me this is this is CNN trying to
remain relevant yes not buzz for you
trying to get crazy because CNN has such
a bad reputation right now I mean yeah
you're right the people I feel the worst
for though are the content creators who
like because they're BuzzFeed is sharing
other people's stuff or you know they do
have their authors that create their own
articles but I feel bad for the videos
that they pull CNN is gonna take videos
that people made and that those people
aren't gonna get in the ad revenue right
CNN and BuzzFeed are gonna get the
revenue and that's what bothers me as a
content creator right it's just like I'm
so used to other people taking my money
and that sucks right all right well
that's a slight sidebar but I think
that's kind of interesting so basically
what you're saying is they're gonna
embed all these clips but do they do it
in their own player is that I usually
take it from YouTube so if they take it
from YouTube aren't you still getting
the clips or the clicks oh yeah no if
they if it's yeah embedded from YouTube
on their site like BuzzFeed you probably
still get the the revenue but on CNN is
when they're playing something like on
TV yeah does this just go to show that
like big media will destroy it this is
sort of reminds me of like Yahoo and
tumblr like we're just waiting for
tumblr to be destroyed now and I feel
like that's what's the other next up
will be like Anderson Cooper hosting
Blue's Clues or something you know yeah
that would be good you know his ratings
are not good like why not feel
why not just yeah all right Anderson
there you heard it from Whitney take 15%
on the contract I that alright let's
talk to let's talk about basically the
hottest thing on the internet as sad as
that may be miss amanda Bynes you know
when I started doing the show the whole
point was not to do these like trivial
nonsensical pop-culture things but this
is the type of thing that is kind of
jumped into mainstream and I think we
can kind of make it a bigger a bigger
topic so she was a child actress she was
on Nickelodeon she was on right
Nickelodeon she was in that movie she's
the man I actually thought that was kind
of cute and basically she's gone bonkers
she's sending out these crazy tweets you
guys have all heard about this stuff she
may have thrown a bong out her window
and got arrested last week so my first
question you know what let's show let's
show some some of her stuff and then
we'll go from there so that's her at her
court hearing last week I believe that
might be a wig I'm not 100% sure let's
look at a couple of the tweets I want at
Drake to murder my vagina
all right yeah I have a feeling you'll
both have some ideas on that I think we
have one more where we got a couple more
here
Rihanna no one wants to be your lover so
you can call everyone and their mother
that I almost named my dude
new dog Rihanna was that supposed to
rhyme I read it as if it was gonna rhyme
I don't know
Rihanna Chris Brown beat you because
you're not pretty enough and Rihanna you
look so ugly trying to be white I did
not know that Rihanna was trying to be
white okay so where do we start here do
we think this is all real even or is
this just like somebody trying to hang
on to their last little bit of famine I
think it's I think manda Bynes Twitter
is fake I think whatever is going on
with her in the real world is it's real
and those pictures are stolen weight
from or whatever sure real thing her
Twitter is not verified let's throw that
out okay so that's true the Twitter
there is no blue check yeah yeah famous
blue check it is not on earth
so you think it literally is not her I
don't think that Twitter is heart now I
just think that the the correlation
that's going between the tweets and like
let's say that image of her in the
courtroom seems to have a pretty you
know positive correlation there yeah you
think there's some love her so much
yeah I grew up watching her she was one
of my idols and to see this happen I'm
just like no it's not her yeah Niall is
that your Amanda Bynes tonight
what is our fascination with watching
it's always girls we seem to have a
thing about girls destroying themselves
so great Bieber inside right now it's
Charlie Sheen good one right but Charlie
Sheen is an adult man so he's still an
adult there something about teen girls
we look you know so Brittany and Lindsay
Lohan you know even if they're a young
20s let's say we love watching them the
transverse adult men and Justin Bieber
who I think may be a teen girl so that
is the quarry yeah one of them literally
destroyed himself and the other one yeah
but what is it about girls I think or
this teen girl thing I mean I think it's
just we have a fascination with the
media in general so when you get to
something you know people have this you
know kind of car wreck fascination they
want to in a way see this kind of demise
unfold you know and it's like it's how
we why we turn into tune in so so deeply
- you know when disasters strike the
world it could be an area that you've
never even heard of but you're so you
know indebted to it you're so invested
into that situation because people are
just fascinated with that other and you
know they don't know what to expect and
it's it's why people are so into reality
television I think you know it's like
you don't know what to expect and it's
really happening you can't write this
stuff yeah like you can if you wrote
what he was doing people would be like
this is the most ridiculous thing I've
ever this would never happen yeah but
she look she's legitimately standing in
court with one of it's not even like a
wig it's like she she was like let me
find the worst wig that I could find
what happened summer it fell out right
it's starting to fall out because of
over processing so she shaved her entire
head now she's wearing a wig nonetheless
the wig is a bit over the top you could
get something a little more demure right
exactly and now with the whole even this
morning I don't know if you've heard
there's a new attack on Twitter with
Chrissy Teigen she's a Sports
Illustrated model I guess and for some
reason she keeps using the word ugly and
in my adulthood and yours I mean had you
ever use the word ugly it's like being
on the playground again yeah like it's
like she should like kick their shin I'm
like run away after yeah do you think
there's something we as someone that
sympathizes with a young amanda bynes do
you think there's something like I think
the only thing we could probably do to
help her would be ignore her like for me
like I have officially sworn off I never
tweet about the Kardashians any more
because to me that's the only way we can
stop them you know what I mean we can't
keep feeding it there any lighting thing
I was like no more Kardashian's I'm
willing to give up the jokes yeah for
the greater good thank you aren't you
like aching to talk about Kim's feet
though they keep showing pictures of her
you got ten seconds I miss her feet are
so swollen because she's so pregnant and
she keeps wearing like these heels so
she's jamming your feet and they just
keep taking pictures of her feet all
right well I give you guys permission to
pause this for a second and Google Kim
Kardashian's feet because obviously it's
mocking of her but really what can we do
to help poor Amanda we carry practically
started a kind of like recovery group
for online started bike none of the none
other than Courtney Love
yeah and now Alyssa Milano has jumped on
board and basically I think they're
gonna have some kind of celebrity
intervention it's Ariana Alyssa Milano
Courtney Love like do these people
really care about each other or
everyone's are trying to get their
points right
business like she is she needs to sign
herself into some whatever yeah facility
and that's the only way she's gonna get
helped like you have to be wanting and
willing to get help
she keeps claiming she is allergic to
drugs and alcohol that's what she said
yeah and that she is mental illness have
you ever met anyone that's allergy to
drugs
I don't even know what that means yeah
how does she know she's allergic to
drugs without having that's like saying
I'm allergic to food I mean there's a
lot of different drugs you can't be
alert yeah alright let's let's move on
let's talk about bisexuality it is the
hottest of all the sexualities these
days and there was an article in The New
York Times last week where they were
talking about coming out as bisexual at
work and why that is difficult and I got
a quote here I just want to read this is
one of one of the ladies talking about
coming out of her office she said it
never seems appropriate to say the word
sexual in a work environment
and it's simply awkward if I came out to
a straight man for example he would seem
to take it in a sexual way coming out to
women I just get scared that they were
that they will be uncomfortable or think
I'm coming on to them also it gets
really wordy which is the tough part I
guess for bisexuals and we have a noted
bisexual here at this table Bree you are
by sight I whispered it to you before
even yeah I hate the word you represent
all bisexuals now so ok I my I feel like
my case is very different and I feel
like I relate more to pansexual people
but I for me personally it's not about
liking guys or girls it's about liking
whoever I fall in love with ok so how is
that different for the layman how's that
how's bisexual different than Pancer
because I wouldn't well pansexual is you
like everyone I I don't really know the
exact definition of pansexual I've heard
so many different things about that and
I I just don't like to be I feel like
bisexuality has such a stigma and it's
just not fair like people don't take it
seriously so I hate using the word I
just if I am
attracted to a woman I'll say I'm
attracted to this woman you know what I
mean it's just it's hard especially in
the workplace it really depends on where
you work I think that it's safe to say
anything at all does that seem legit to
you like there's this idea that if
you're bisexual it's like oh you're just
so horny all the time you'll just do it
with anyone anywhere that is not fair
only fair no I think I think the thing
is this article you know it's like when
she said that I feel like if I talk say
the word bisexual to a man then he'll
think that you know I'm hitting on
heaven if a woman the same thing and I
think the response honestly the way I
feel yeah you're probably right because
you probably should if they're not your
friends at work and they don't get where
you're coming from you probably
shouldn't be talking about sex right why
would you be you or you probably are
hitting on them you know it's like why
are you bringing it's not like oh yeah
I'd open it for breakfast and I had sex
with a woman last night Yeah right but
is it a bit of a problem with that that
been only a gay person or a bisexual
person would have to deal with that
cause a straight person you come into
work in the morning and talk to a
stranger about like you know meeting a
hot guy laughs I mean you know it's just
not appropriate there's certain things
until you've developed that kind of safe
zone and Trust with someone and they're
considered your friend and you would
have that conversation you know at a
coffee shop at a bar it's like keep
business business you don't go into work
talking about how straight you are
outside exactly you know the thing is
then you get into the whole sexual
harassment thing because those same
women or men you know will be the first
to be filed some sexual harassment
rightfully so if something were to
happen but it's like you're opening up
that that sector and I think it's just
not a perfect it I'm actually surprised
to hear you say that because it seems to
me that a woman let's say a woman was a
lesbian and she goes to work and at the
watercooler in the morning there's
someone that she so happens to work with
and they said well what'd you do last
night
and she said I went on a date with a
girl so you think that no that's
appropriate that's appropriate cuz I
went on a date I'm dating this woman you
don't have to be like oh not the broader
yeah you don't have to say I went on a
date with a girl last night cuz you're
like that's besides the point if you
want to
sexuality accepted in this country you
have to remove that kind of like I went
on a date and it was with a woman yeah
you know it's no I happen to go on a
date or I'm dating someone she is
awesome yeah well I want to keep
focusing on bisexuality here for a
second because there is an idea at least
with with gays and maybe more with gay
men that bisexuality does not exist so
you are a lesbian look at this we got
gay guy bisexual chicken always be on a
panel I think this is the first time in
the history of anything do you believe
in bisexuality yeah absolutely you know
and when she was saying
pansexual I think I think for me the
term pansexual kind of embodies like
genderqueer you know like however you
identify his gender and sexuality are
two different things you know so I think
pansexual bisexual might be like I am
attracted to both men and women
pansexual at least in my eyes is more
like you know it doesn't matter if your
gender in your sexuality match like I'm
gonna fall in love with you as a person
yeah do you think when you've told
people that year by do you think guys
somehow get off on it more like there's
you know like if a girl says she's a
lesbian well the guys like alright I'm
out nothing I can do but somehow they're
gonna end up with you and five other
chicks because that's how this may be
getting personal I've had mixed
responses but I know from people that
I've been in a row in relationships with
it's scary it's a scary thing to them
and it's it's a threatening thing
because now there's double the
competition which is that Woody Allen
joke or whatever I don't know the
whatever that joke was but um yeah I
mean it depends it really depends some
guy I mean it depends on what type of
guy you're talking to a lot of guys are
very mature believe it or not and they
are very mature and they don't then they
say okay and they are you know accepting
yeah what do you guys think about guys
when it comes to bisexuality because
deaf I mean you hear this all the time
like a girl in college can make out with
the girl and nobody thinks anything of
it but you never hear of like through
straight guys me I mean if a guy makes
all that I hear about it
happy yeah I mean they see the stems
back to just general acceptance and
gender roles in society and like we live
in a still patriarchal society we're
like it's okay for women you know it's
still that it has sexual association
where it's like hot and safe it doesn't
kind of challenge the male
heteronormative kind of structure
whereas like I'm sure most guys or a lot
of guys I don't know but I'm not one but
maybe you can answer this better have
you at least made out or maybe like a
circle jerk you know this is [ __ ] we
gotta move on okay let's uh we're gonna
keep it with gender for just a second so
the hub network which they say is aimed
at kids but they have the old school
transformers and GI Joe on there so I
watch all the time they are coming out
with a new cartoon it is called shezow
and let's watch a little of the promo
the boy who became a superhero to save
the world turns into
my mama dude no he's a girl this dress
is uncomfortable no she's the boy who's
no he says no he's she's the boy who's a
guy are you ready to kick some she's out
he's just a guy exactly making the world
a safer place
clever as a girl
she's the new hub series check your
local listings
all right so in case you weren't clear
what just happened there he's a 12 year
old boy puts on a ring becomes a
superhero girl I actually had very
similar experience when I was that age
all right is this part of the hardcore
left-wing liberal progressive agenda to
turn all our boys into girls because you
know that's coming I think it's just a
silly concept and I think people are
making such a huge deal out of it for no
reason at all
yeah although I would be offended if I
started to watch it and I you know was
thinking that maybe they're making fun
of it in a way then I would be a say in
front of trans yes in front of girls cuz
when I just was watching that the first
thing I noticed was when he first turned
into a girl he was like no yes it's like
that's like the worst thing you can be
right well that's the funny thing it's
like if they wanted it if they were
trying to be Pro trans or Pro
cross-dressing or something exactly and
in this it's like he is still playing on
this no it's not right kind of thing
which I think takes away from whatever
the controversy would be yeah you go
ahead I'm just saying I know their
target demographic is 2 to 11 and I
really don't think these kids are
sitting there right analyzing whether or
not like they're like oh man like this
transgender thing is really like you
know stirring the pot you know I think
they're just seeing this boy it's
entertaining if anything it's smart
because you're appealing to the little
boy market in the girl market you know
as one in the same and that equals money
and that is smart yeah it's very
accurate actually because if you want to
save the world you kind of have to be a
woman yeah do you have a special ring I
do you do it and yet you're not wearing
it's a nuvaring
very good you know it's funny I remember
when I was a kid watching Shira and
watching Jim and Jim was made by the
same people with the same animators that
made GI Joe and transformers and Shira
was made by the he-man people but I
remember thinking that I was doing
something wrong because I was watching
it because it was aimed at girls did you
guys have that kind of thing where you
maybe watched like a GI Joe or something
where that seemed more boyish and like
do I wonder if girls have that or was it
all about Barbies and I liked Power
Rangers and there were some girls there
so that's okay I I'm I like mixed
company I'm bisexual so I like everyone
I like guys and girls yeah I mean yeah I
understand that I I feel like I got a
comment the other day about this guy
saying it's a bad that I watch Pretty
Little Liars and I was like dude own it
that shows amazing nice of all what is
that yeah even in adults that we think
that somehow watching something is good
like are straight people hanging on to
their identity by such a is that what it
is because people don't watch gay people
are inundated with straight images all
the time aren't suddenly like well I
better be straight with straight people
if they see anything gay they're like oh
my god guys watching the notebook was
like I mean it was okay like all right I
just had to go with her you know but I
think it goes back to that whole
challenging that kind of you know male
perception of strength and
heterosexuality but it's like if you
look back in the history of cartoons
it's not like this is the first time
that the homosexual or transgender or
any type of plan that has been
represented I mean you have Batman and
Robin Boy Wonder you know you have Fred
Flintstone who you know was Twinkletoes
Flintstone hung out with Barney like all
the time yeah Bugs Bunny was a
crossdresser all his money know Popeye
was a sailor who was dating of olive oil
could have been as transition ever no
yeah yeah well it seems to me that
there's the one part of this that I
think is that they're aiming it at kids
and people seem to think that we can
we can turn kids and that's the scary
part here that that still exists is the
is the bigger problem right I think that
is a huge problem
I think people are reading too much into
it I think it's just a silly little
cartoon I don't I don't see the problem
with it at all if anything it's just
making people it's making people watch
something that's about a guy and a girl
at the same time yeah and also kids just
don't realize this stuff right like when
I was 10 watching Bugs Bunny and he was
cross-dressing like I never thought it
was sexual like it just seemed funny to
me so it's like yeah
the irony is that like really with them
making this more of an issue it's like
that it's bringing it to life you know I
don't think it would have even been
noticed or by kids or anything yeah
ironically we're gonna have this for
kids but are there any trans characters
on television are there much there might
be one or two but like any sort of
mainstream in the accident anyone yes
and she has yeah
Candis Cayne used to be on oh god what
show is it I can't do you know I can't
escape yeah she she had a role on some
mainstream show yeah I think that what
do I see yeah all right well I guess we
got a way to go but the people of hub
will lead us to gender equality all
right last last topic so Walmart you've
probably heard of them they're probably
in your neighborhood destroying the
local economy right this very second
they were fine this week eighty two
million dollars for violating the Clean
Water Act basically you can guess what
this is I mean they're just dumping crap
in to the water we then drink the water
we wash our faces with the water all
that good stuff this was they violated
six counts of the Clean Water Act it was
filed by prosecutors in LA and San
Francisco they disposed of chemicals
improperly all this and you can guess of
course they have the money and there's
no reason to think they're ever gonna
change is there anything we can do to
stop you know we talk about this stuff
all the time Young Turks is built on
trying to sort of stop these giant
corporations from doing all these evil
things and abusing money and power and
politics is there anything that can be
done with this stuff where it's just
like all right
fine move on and that's it pay the fine
yeah
I don't know I'm really not surprised
though that this happened because I see
a lot of butt cracks go in and I wanna
surprise so you think there's a
correlation between butt crack crap and
crap very good thank you yeah a little
bit yeah
Whitney is there anything we can do to
stop these giant companies from doing
this kind of thing you know
unfortunately money talks in this
country and it will buy your way out of
anything literally they will pay this
fine in 25.4 hours of their time that
they're open for so it's like you know a
drop in the bucket not even you know
it's like mist yeah and and I think
until I don't even know a solution I
don't even know I think if anything that
would even remotely affect anything
would be putting people in jail and
holding people personally accountable
but that will never happen because they
have executives don't go to jail in
America we don't know bankers go to jail
I know corporate executives ever go yeah
right well that's the point I mean none
of these people ever be the most like
they I think oh you know what just
arrest all of them exactly no it'll be
fine you know but it's like that's funny
like they're gonna fire the guy who they
don't like pull the switch the minimum
was like but that would be what would
happen most likely you know and it's
just like man and they will never be
held accountable and the the one thing
that really just ticked me off was in
reading it you know I think vice
president or something like that said
one of the first responses was that
we're pleased with the outcome and this
will not affect our fiscal quarter right
because that's what it's all yeah yeah
so if we can't do anything like these
companies are we all to blame because I
truth be told I moved here a couple
months ago I did go to Walmart and I was
gonna buy a TV and actually they were
serviced there was literally so shitty I
brought the TV up a 50-inch TV carried
it to the register and the servicemen
show so shitty I just left it there and
left but I do shop at Target all the
times
and you know I got like grill at Lowe's
or I don't float up just tossing them in
my pool yeah my point is we all do this
stuff so are we all to blame because I'm
guessing you guys have both probably
shopped at Walmart right in the past yes
I have officially given it up though
okay but I will say companies like that
should be ashamed of themselves for
doing something like that but at the end
of the day are we to blame yeah do we do
this in our everyday lives too
yeah without knowing it are we dumping
chemicals without knowing it yeah all
the time like regular people are doing
it too so I mean just playing devil's
advocate you're you know a lot of people
are not informed at all have you have
you guys seen these new commercials for
Walmart where they now are pretending
that they're getting all the stuff from
local produce people and all their fruit
and vegetables they're making it seem
like it's all organic and you know and
I'm sure some of that is true but still
the amount of mom and pops that are
gonna go under and the farms that are
gonna go under because you can but we
just want cheap [ __ ] Yeah right thank
you the service was so shitty the other
day because they were all busy pouring
out counts no I I mean if I
the thing is in Los Angeles I feel like
Walmart doesn't really have a strong
presence so I feel like it's like just
does it even hardly it hardly exists I
feel like right now tart at Target or
Target and Diary feel better at all
right now interestingly tarjay or Target
or Target has done some anti-gay stuff
not to bring everything around to gay
but so how do as members of the LGBT
community how do you guys feel about
like I won't go to chick-fil-a but I do
go to Target so what does that say I
mean we're it's not gonna stop us right
well you know what I mean we're still
gonna be gay and bi at the end of the
day communique and what a good deal is a
possible
that's what I'm saying not funny people
who are gay people to like stand up for
everything all the time and oh we got to
always be better I'm like sick of being
better yeah yeah we're I wanted to ask
you guys cuz I think you do have
something kind of interesting going on
together is that the way you guys have
become public figures you in the in the
digital space and in the YouTube world
and you from reality TV this is the
future of media I firmly believe that
which is why I'm doing this how does it
feel in terms of being a public figure
in this new world like we're not TV
stars we're not movie stars per se or
I've never been in a movie so not per se
literally but that you're a public
person in the digital space how does
that feel in 2013 for a youtuber it
feels good because I'm a normal person
I'm not a celebrity whatsoever and if
anyone says otherwise I correct them
don't worry I'm nobody but seriously
it's it's it's interesting it's if you
can't if you go on auditions all the
time because I wanna be an actress week
on auditions all the time and you're not
getting parts that you want why not
create it yourself put yourself out
there build an audience yourself that's
the only way up now is such a gamble
yeah and Whitney for you you came from
the reality world and that reality seems
to be I think we may be finally a little
bit how do you how do you blend like
what your public persona is do people
expect you to be the reality person I
mean well I think what I kind of lucked
out because I when I went into it I just
was kind of like ah this is me
uncensored you know and looking back
sometimes I was shocked and appalled at
myself but you know I think that when
people meet me in real life I think that
they knew what they were getting and
they see me and it's the same thing and
it kind of transferred over fairly
equally so you know I I think having my
personality kind of consolidated down
into 45 minutes it seems like I'm a
always at that time had always a new
girlfriend or cocktail in my hand which
is not true it's only half the time I'm
married now but now I think people
pretty much see what they can get and I
hope that I come out as you know being
just being relatable yeah you know and
people I would hope feel comfortable
approaching me and then you know I can
be a voice but at the same time you know
be real and have faults yeah
all right so final thought on this how
empowering is it to you guys to sort of
own your brand and everything right now
like even 10 years ago like if you
wanted to be a public entertainer or
whatever it is we all are like the
network owned you or you were you know
had to take gigs that you didn't want
because your manager your agent want to
and now there's all these people I mean
there are youtubers that are way bigger
than the two of us that are making
literally millions of dollars it's
pretty empowering to just own your stuff
right
it feels amazing and I do have a manager
but he's so cool he lets me own YouTube
like everything I do on YouTube is mine
yeah and that's such a great feeling
because I've had networks screw me over
YouTube network they are noted for that
Oh YouTube networks yeah yeah so to be
on your own as an independent youtuber
or part of a network that is very
accepting and there they may know what
you want and they want to help you
that's just that feels great yeah and
what about for you because you're I feel
like you're always doing like a little
bit of everything and yeah but it's you
and you're owning it yeah it's me I mean
it's been an amazing opportunity to like
just create myself into a business it's
like you know kind of going this
alternative route and being able to kind
of blaze your own Trail and you know
it's been really rewarding you know
challenging at times but you know I
think that this is kind of like in this
day and age we get to redefine this
concept of entertainment and I'm glad I
can be part of it for sure how small and
that was a fitting ending Bri thank you
Whitney thank you I think we're gonna go
into some sort of business it's gonna be
like a smaller Walmart kind of thing
environmentally sustainable very
pro-lgbt and all that whole thing it's
been the Rubin report I'm Dave Rubin and
we'll do it again
you